Aloha Rum company is the official Ultra
Premium rum of the Las Vegas Raiders and
today they are giving us something to
cheers to we're so excited to have Frank
kibbish joining us and this bottle is
beautiful Frank thank you so much for
being here thank you for having us so
this is exciting tell us about this well
this is our five-year Barrel aged
commemorative bottle and box
commemorating the 45th anniversary of
the Raiders
first world championship wow it's a
special anniversary and now the Raiders
are part of our community so we get to
be part of that history I think right
and you guys joined the Raiders family
not too long ago tell us about that and
you can actually get this at the games
right uh this won't be available at the
games no but our ROM is available the
stadium yes we have our own branded bar
we have stuff everywhere but uh yeah
this is uh this is special very special
this is a limited edition we've only
made 300 bottles of this and it's only
available in Nevada so how can you get
your hands on it I mean only 300 bottles
people are going to want this stuff yeah
it's there's a few bottles left at Lee's
Liquor at uh 4230 South Rainbow okay but
if you want to just try it we do have a
couple partners of restaurants that have
picked it up such as fuhu and Crossroads
it Resorts World and if you go to
Crossroads you definitely have to try
their new cocktail featuring kaloa rum
it's called Pretty Fly for a mai tai oh
isn't it that's great you guys that you
are originally created in Hawaii right
and you're bringing a taste of the
island out here tell us about the
origination of the brand uh we
originated in 2009 we've been bottling
and Distilling on Kauai uh since then
um we expanded out here uh just a you
know probably about eight years ago
we're in many different countries Canada
Japan uh it's great Australia
um yeah we've been growing like crazy
it's been fantastic you know they call
us the ninth Island out here yeah you
got to bring a taste of it here yeah
absolutely I see there are ice cubes in
the glass are you actually opening this
bottle here today I wanted to offer you
a little sip of the ninth of Hawaii
we have to cheers to that and as you're
tearsing remind us again where people
can come to to get a taste for
themselves so if you want to get a taste
for yourself go to fuhu or Crossroads in
Resorts World all right cheers to that
cheers congratulations this is amazing
this ice cube in itself I'm excited to
take it you guys you gotta get days
we're cheers into the Raiders today as
we